for years Marvel fans assumed natalie
portman was finished playing Jane Foster
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that'll change to San Diego comic-con
2019 when it was announced that she'd
return to wield Nyonya as a Mighty Thor
in 2021 Thor love and thunder but what
brought her back to the MCU Natalie
Portman was widely reported to be
unhappy with Marvel while filming Thor
the dark world according to The
Hollywood Reporter Portman a championed
director patty Jenkins to helm the movie
and was shocked when Jenkins was fired
from the project
Poorman wanted Jenkins to be the first
female director in the MCU and was
blindsided by Jenkins termination as she
was allegedly not told ahead of time and
only learned of it through news reports
unable to leave the project due to
contractual obligations Portman stuck it
out and completed the dark world but
behind the scenes she may not have been
shy about her feelings regarding the
whole ordeal still in public she never
badmouth Marvel when asked about a
relationship with a company in
interviews he was always expertly vague
with her answers Taika Waititi saw
Ragnarok is wildly different from the
first two Thor movies which can't help
it seem stuffy and downright Dawa
compared to the visually splendid comedy
feast ytt gave us let's face it Thor can
sometimes be a bit boring sure he's a
god of thunder but he's also being a
kind of stick-in-the-mud ytt along with
screenwriters Erik Pearson Craig Kyle
and Christopher el Yost managed to keep
the sweet innocence of Thor's character
but made him much more fun-loving and
way less stiff Thor comes into his own
in Ragnarok played perfectly by
Hemsworth whose comedic chops are on
full display Natalie Portman wasn't
going to come back to the Marvel fold
just for anyone by TT's idea for a
female Thor had to be very attractive
for Portman and she must stress whitey
tighties vision to want to sign back up
with a company she said she was done
with just a few years ago for the first
time female Thor
[Applause]
according to studio Chief Kevin Feige
the director when his new star over very
quickly he told CNN we've been in touch
with Natalie she's part of the MCU
family and we put she and Tiger together
it took one meeting and she agreed to do
it if only all creative decisions were
so simple Jane Foster is a world
renowned astrophysicist
but she's often come off as a damsel in
distress in the MCU so it's not a
surprise Natalie Portman spent years
publicly ambivalent about returning to
the character that's combined with the
fallout from Marvel firing patty Jenkins
was more than enough to keep her away
but being offered the chance to play
Jane Foster as the Mighty Thor provides
Portman was so much more than just being
regarded as Thor's ex-girlfriend she
gets to portray another female superhero
in the MCU she wouldn't be seen as
merely a love interest for Thor Odinson
she will be his equal
Portman has used their previous
appearances as dr. Jane Foster to
inspire young women around the world to
get involved in the sciences so the
thoughts of bringing dr. Foster back and
being Thor must have been very appealing
Natalie Portman's Jane Foster has been
one of the most powerful intellects in
the MCU but it beats tough to play a
character dubbed The Mighty Thor without
adding some brawn to that brainpower
importnant is already planning to buff
up for her role in Thor love and thunder
shortly after Marvel's surprise Comic
Con announcement she took to social
media to expressive enthusiasm for the
project posting an Instagram update in
which he pronounced herself thrilled to
share the news and promised to hit the
gym for all that hammer wielding action
she quipped remember this is the before
picture when I get Jack's
for Portland be taking workout tips from
Chris Hemsworth only time will tell but
in the comics Jane Foster spends her
time as a Mighty Thor wiping the floor
with a laundry list of powerful
adversaries that included such heavy
weights as mangog Malekith the Phoenix
force and even Odin himself it'll take
one heck of a gym regimen to prepare her
for whatever she's due to face in Thor
love and thunder Tom Petty wonders that
the waiting is the hardest part
Thor love and thunder hasn't even
started shooting yet according to movie
web the film which is slated for release
in November 2021 won't begin production
until the completion of Marvel's
shang-chi and The Legend of the ten
rings in 2020 this means we've got a
very long wait ahead of us before he
gets a scene Natalie Portman
the rest of the cast and the fourth full
movie Marvel is very good at keeping
secrets so don't expect to hear much
from the sets even after it does finally
start filming but don't feel too bad
Marvel fans the studio will serve up a
few movies to keep us entertained until
thought love and thunder comes out
including Black Widow the Eternals the
aforementioned shang-chi in the legend
of the ten rings and Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness Marvel also
has plenty of upcoming television shows
slated to air on the Disney Plus
streaming channel including Loki
starring Tom Hiddleston that the
countdown to November 2021 begin check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bell to you don't miss a
single one
[Music]